this traditional water mill can grind
over 550 pounds of flour in a single day
this is the logo show what a meal of
wielded down a museum in singleton West
Sussex
the way we make the flour is exactly the
same way as it's been made for
generations it's the week there's him at
the top the flour comes out at the
bottom we don't have anything in at all
we don't take anything else the logo
show meal lates the 17th century but
despite being over 400 years old he
hasn't always been in the same location
its original site was the lager show
village in West Sussex which is named
after the original mill had two water
wheels in tandem each will travel its
own independent set of machinery with
time only the tailwater will remained in
use and the cast iron will replace the
wooden one the lager sawmill was
incorporated into the museum in 1973 the
museum carried out restoration works of
the machinery and the interior but he
was still lacking something essential
the problem was but on this site we
don't have a river so we have to
engineer of a water system dig out a big
pond unlined it because underneath this
chalk which absorbs water and then below
the wheel we need another pond to
collect the water that had to be dug out
and lined
and the coasters my river we have to
pump that water back up and reuse it
nowadays the nail is used for grinding
corn flour and animal feed
it's applies to more Baker's and farm
shops around the singleton village we
follow the journey of a bag of wheat as
it is milled into flour the mill is
structured over three floors the top
floor where grain is fed from the first
floor or stone floor where the grinding
takes place and the ground floor or spot
floor where horizontal shaft connects
the waterwheel to the machinery the
Mills driven by water and so we need to
have water flowing over the waterwheel
we start the mill by taking a very large
spammer up to the sluice gates which
control where the water comes out of the
big mill point we open the sluice gate
water then flows along a channel at the
back of the mill until it reaches the
waterwheel and it starts to fill up what
we call buckets they don't look like the
bucket that you would use for cleaning
the floor or something like that but
they each slot contains water and we
need to fill about four of those before
the weight of the water makes the wheel
turn and then the water tops up the next
one and the next one so it keeps turning
continuously the mill is 12 feet in
diameter when grinding it turns at about
6 revolutions per minute each complete
turn is powered by 200 gallons of water
when we need to mill we take the bag
into the middle and we use a chain hoist
to lift it up to the top floor of the
mill
[Music]
we then open the bag sometimes the
string will pull sometimes we have to
use scissors and we then pour it down
the chute into a hopper above the
machinery
[Music]
in this big barrel there are two stones
just like these miniature ones the
bottom one called the bad stone that
doesn't move the top one called the
runner stone is turned by the machinery
and it's the one that is actually doing
the grinding we can control the grade of
the flour by the amount of grain that we
put in and the distance apart of the
stones and everything is checked by
what's known as the rule of thumb with
no gauges no machinery we just use our
thumb and our forefinger and if it feels
right it is right over all the stones
rotate thirteen and a half times each
rotation of the waterwheel at an average
speed of 80 revolutions per minute I
enjoy the fact that when I come to the
museum at the end of the day I can look
at a ton of fans as I help to make that
and because we are also a museum and we
have visitors it's fascinating to talk
to the visitors and some of them tell me
stories about how they've seen a mill
being used when they were children and
get people who come from various parts
of the world telling us how they was
used one lady from Cambodia told me how
to make rice noodles using one
you